is Netflix better with or without ads
well that depends who you are one of
Netflix's great attractions compared to
Conventional linear television is that
you don't get interrupted by a series of
cards every 15 minutes or so that's
about to change not for everyone but for
anybody who doesn't want to Pony up the
15 that a standard US subscription might
cost Netflix is going to roll out and
add supported tier starting in 2023
it'll be cheaper but you will have to
stomach a few commercials every now and
then it is of course the model that used
to support all media magazines
newspapers radio television even your
buses were partly subsidized by the ads
that peppered them back in 2006 the New
York Times was able to charge its
subscribers an average of 534 dollars a
year but it made an additional 1064 a
year from advertisers in fact it was
able to keep its subscription fees
broadly flat as ad prices increased
those economics have largely been
unpicked in the years since by the
arrival of AD Tech giants like Google
and Facebook who between them Hoover up
the Lion's Share of advertising spending
that has in turn heralded the arrival of
subscription services such as Netflix
Disney plus and HBO Max as media
companies seek new business models but
those companies come with their own
problems as long as they're dependent
upon subscriptions alone their growth
potential is restricted by the number of
subscribers they can attract and how
much they can charge them and both of
those numbers are getting squeezed by
the increasing pressure on people's
wallets and mounting competition in
online streaming as broadcasters pile
into the space in fact Netflix lost
almost 2 million subscribers in North
America in the first six months of 2022
alone having an ad supported tier may
help solve both of those problems it of
course makes a subscription more
affordable Bloomberg News has reported
that fixed plans to charge seven dollars
a month about half as much as the
standard subscription rate that should
attract more subscribers or at the very
least reduce the Hemorrhage of existing
ones it might also make it easier to
make more money from each subscriber
without having to increase the price of
a subscription take Hulu the streaming
service controlled by Disney it makes
6.50 a month in ads for every user on
its ad supported tier in addition to the
seven dollar subscription fee it charges
according to an estimate from Bloomberg
intelligence analyst Gita ranganathan if
Netflix charges seven dollars a month
and can make a similar amount in ads
it'll already be making considerably
more than it does from its current
entry-level subscription which is 9.99
what's more if it can increase the
amount that it charges advertisers over
time investors will get excited about
its growth prospects this all Heralds a
massive change for online streaming and
has the advertising industry brimming
with excitement they long considered
streaming services aversion to add a
colossal missed opportunity to flog
people more stuff yes there were
offerings such as foxes to be and
Amazon's freebie that were 100 AD funded
but other services have joined the party
in recent years Netflix and Disney plus
were the biggest holdouts but have both
now come on board many of the top
streaming services now have more
subscribers on the ad supported tier
than on the pricier ad free one why well
the secret might be that New Media is
discovering something that old media
knew long ago ads are lucrative if
you've got a committed audience you
might even be able to charge advertisers
more over time
you might not like ads but Netflix might
find that they're actually better for
its business
[Music]